let me ask you a trick tricky one in the
recent news that's become especially
relevant uh for me what do you think
about if you've been paying attention to
yay Kanye West
a recent controversial Outburst on
social media about
and
Jews
black people
racism General
slavery Holocaust all these topics that
he touched on in different ways on
different platforms but including
Twitter what do you do with that and
like what do you do what do you do with
that ethma platform perspective what do
you do from a Humanity perspective of
how to add love to the world
let's um should we take both sides of
them sure option one is he is
completely out of line and option two is
he's not just the same sure right so the
path one
is
he is an incredibly important taste
maker in the world
that defines the belief system for a lot
of people
and there just is no room
for any form of racism or bias or
anti-Semitism in today's day and age
particularly by people
whose words and comments will be
Amplified around the world
we've already paid a large price for
that and then the expectation
of success is some amount of societal
decorum that keeps moving the ball
forward
the other side would say
life
I think goes from Harmony to disharmony
to repair
and anybody who has gone through a very
complicated divorce
will tell you that in that moment your
life is extremely disharmonious
and you are struggling to cope
and because he is famous
we are seeing
a person really struggling in a moment
that may need help
and we owe it to him
not for what he said because that stuff
isn't excusable
but we owe it to him
to help him in a way and particularly
his friends
and if he has real friends
hopefully what they see is that what I
see on the outside looking in
is a person that is clearly struggling
can I ask you like a human question and
I know it's outside looking in but
there's several questions I want to ask
so one is about the pain of going
through a divorce and having kids and
all that kind of stuff and two when
you're rich and powerful and famous I
don't know maybe you can enlighten me to
which is the most corruptive
um but how do you know who are the
friends
to trust
so a lot of the world is calling Kanye
insane and if orlick has mental illness
all that kind of stuff and so how do you
have friends close to you let's say
let's say something like that message
but from a place of
uh love and where they actually care for
you as opposed to trying to get you to
shut up
the reason I ask all those questions I
think
if you care about the guy how do you
help him right
I've been through a divorce it's gut
wrenching
the most horrible part is having to tell
your kids
I can't even describe it to you
um how proud I am of and how resilient
these three beautiful little creatures
were when my ex-wife and I had to sit
them down and talk through it
um and for that thing I'll be just so
protective of them and so proud of them
and
um it's hard now I don't know that
that's what he went through
um but it doesn't matter in that moment
there's no Fame there's no money there's
nothing there's just the raw intimacy of
a nuclear family
breaking up in that there is a death
and it's the death of that idea
and that is extremely extremely
profound in its impact especially in
your children
[Music]
um it is really hard really hard could
you have seen yourself in the way you
see the world being clouded during
especially at first to where you would
make poor decisions outside of your
outside of that nuclear family so like
business poor business decisions poor
tweeting decisions poor uh I think that
writing decision if I had to boil down
a lot of those what I would say is that
there are moments in my life lacks where
I have felt meaningfully less than
and in those moments the loop that I
would fall into is I would look to cope
and be seen by other people so I would
throw away
all of the work I was doing around my
own internal validation
and I would try to say something or do
something that would get the attention
of others and oftentimes you know when
that Loop was
um was unproductive it's because those
things had really crappy consequences so
you know that was that was yeah so yeah
I I went through that as well so I had
to go through you know this
disharmonious phase in my life and then
to repair it you know I had the benefit
of meeting someone and building a
relationship
um block by block
where there is just enormous
accountability
where
my partner not had has
just incredible empathy
um but accountability
and so she can put herself in my shoes
sometimes when I'm a really tough person
to be around
but then she doesn't let me off the hook
she can forgive me but it doesn't make
you know what I may have said or
whatever you know uh excusable
and that's been really healthy for me
and it's helped me repair my
relationships
be a better parent you know be a better
friend to my ex-wife who's a beautiful
woman who you know I love deeply and
will always love her and it took me a
few years to see that that it was just a
chapter that had come to an end but
she's an incredible mother and an
incredible businesswoman and I'm so
thankful that I've had two incredible
women in my life
that's like a blessing but it's hard so
with that it's hard to find a person
that has that I mean a lot of stuff you
said is pretty profound but having that
person who has empathy and
accountability so basically that's
ultimately what great friendship is
which is people that love you have
empathy for you but can also call you
out on your [ __ ] she's a LeBron
james-like figure and the reason I say
that is
I've seen and met so many people I've
seen the Distribution on the scale of
friendship and empathy
she's the LeBron James with friendship
she's a goat well what's so funny is
like you know we have a dinner around
poker
and it's taken on a life of its own
mostly because of her because these guys
look to her
and I'm like whoa whoa
[Laughter]
her registers are already full she's
thinking of all kinds of crap with me
um but um
but it's a it's a it's a very innate
skill and it's paired with you know it's
but it's not just an emotional thing
meaning
she's the person that I make all my
decisions with
these decisions we're making together as
a team I've never understood that you
know there's that African pop proverb
like go fast go alone go far ago
together
and
Lex since since I was born I was by
myself
and I had to cope and I didn't have a
good tool kit to use into the world
and in these last five or six years
she's helped me and at first my toolkit
was literally like
sticks you know and then I found a way
to you know she helped me sharpen a
Little Rock and that became a little
knife but even that was crap and then
she showed me fire and then I forged a
knife and that and that's what it feels
like where now this toolkit is like most
average people
and I feel
humbled to be average because I was here
down here on the ground
so it's made all these things more
reasonable so I see
what comes from having deep profound
friendships and love to help you through
these critical moments I have another
friend who
um who I would say just completely
unabashedly loves me this guy Rob
Goldberg he doesn't hold me accountable
that much which I love like I could say
I killed a homeless person he's like ah
they probably deserved it you know
whereas that would be like that was not
good well you just did so but I have
both I mean I have Nat every day you
know Rob I don't talk to that often but
to have two people
I had zero I think most people
unfortunately have zero
um so I think like what what he needs
is somebody to just listen
you don't have to put a label on these
things
and you just have to try to guide in
these very unique moments where you can
just like de-escalate
what is going on in your mind and I
suspect what's going on in his mind
again to play Armstrong quarterback I
don't know
is that he is in a moment where he just
feels lower than low
and we all do it we've all had these
moments where we don't know how to get
attention
and if you didn't grow up in a healthy
environment you may go through a
negative way to get attention
and it's not to excuse it
but it's to understand it
that's so profound the feeling less than
and
at those low points going externally to
find it and maybe creating
conflict
and Scandal to get that attention
the way that my doctor explained it to
me is um
you have to think about yourself worth
like a knot it's inside of a very
complicated set of knots so it's like a
some people don't have these knots it's
just presented to you on a platter
but for some of us because of the way we
grow up it's covered in all these knots
so the whole goal
is to loosen those knots
and it happens slowly it happens
unpredictably and it takes a long time
and so while you're doing that you are
going to have moments where when you
feel less than you're not prepared to
look inside and say actually here's how
I feel about myself it's pretty cool I'm
happy with how where I'm at